こぉんにちは！
はじめしゃちょーです(ﾄﾞﾔ
皆さんは、卵かけご飯は好きですかぁ？
ボックはねぇ…
すぅ　♪
きぃ　♪
;`;:ﾞ;･(;ﾟ;Д ﾟ;)ﾌﾞｫｴｴｴｪｯ
(一息に)ﾊｲ卵かけご飯はご飯に非加熱の鶏の卵をかけ
それを混ぜたご飯の料理の事でございます。
主な調味料としては醤油が使われますねっ。
まぁその他いろんなアレンジがあるんですが…
(一気に)まぁ簡単に要約すればご飯に醤油をぶっかけて
作る料理の事でございます。一般家庭でもよく作られます。
みんなも作ったことあるよね？
そうだろ？
そうだよなぁ？(威圧)
そうって言えよ###(ﾒﾝﾁ)
そうって言えよ(ちょっと弱)
卵かけご飯、色んな言い方があります
「卵ぶっかけご飯」「卵ごはん」…
「卵☆かっけ」
「学名：タマゴカケ」
「TAMAGO MESHI(ﾁｪｹﾗ」
「タマっつる」
「ぼっかけ♂ご飯」
☆―…「T K G」☆―…
…とも呼ばれていますね。
まぁ今回は卵かけご飯に関する動画でございます。
という訳でそもそも卵かけご飯の
歴史についてまずは教えましょう。
そもそも古来より日本人が食べる動物性の食品はね、
仏教の教えのルールなどにより魚介類が中心だったので
獣や鶏肉の肉が食べれるのは稀であったのです。
仏教の教えのルールなどにより
魚介類が中心だったんだな！(ここまでｶﾝﾍﾟ)
鳥類が生んだ卵は昔はな？
人間が食べるものとみなされなかったんDA☆
人間が食した場合は　TU★MI　に
当たると考えられていたそうです。
そ↑して↓　江戸時代っ！
ペットとして飼われるようになった鶏の産んだ卵が
それが無精卵だったら
羽化しないから生物では無いという認識(噛)になり、
それから卵かけご飯のスタートとなった訳でございます。
っと訳で今回は卵かけご飯！
皆さん作ったことあると思うんけれど
もぉ↑！！
あのな？↑
そもそもな↑？
どうせアレだろっ？
こうワッってパカッてご飯に落として
クルクルやってハイ出来た(ﾟ∀ﾟ)
みたいな感じで
SHO↑?!
甘いんだよ↑!!
ｱﾏｲｯ☆彡
とゅ訳で今回はですね、誰でも簡単に作れる
スーパー卵かけご飯。通称…
…というのを、教え(おせぇ)ようと思う！
ま、ＴＶとかネットで見たんですねど
NE (素に戻る
という訳で簡単にエアリー卵かけご飯の説明をしよう
そもそも卵を NA ？
フッツ―は NA ？
割って NA ？
ご飯に NA ？
かけて NA ？
混ぜて NA ？
醤油を KA KE RU
これで完成っていうのが まぁ
一般的なパターンでございます。
しかし NA ？
これじゃあ NA ？
完璧に美味しい卵かけご飯にはならないんですよ。
ＡＭＡＩ んだよ！
そもそも何が駄目かっていうのを教えてあげまShou！
卵っていうのは NA ？
黄身と白身に分かれてるんだ！
DE  NA ？
そのまま卵をパカッてやっちゃうと NA ？
黄身と白身の割合が適当にこう
ランダムになっちゃってネ？
均等な卵かけご飯ができない訳なんです
なのでそれをカイテｔ…
それを解決するための最強の卵かけご飯を今日は
教えようと(低評価)
思う(高評価)
ﾊｲ用意するものはこちらです
醤油・お椀・ご飯…　ｳ゛ｩ゛ｴｪｯ(;ﾟ;Д ﾟ;)
たまぁ～ごぉ～ vV
って訳でまずはご飯を準備します
コシヒカリです。
ホ カ ホ カ でございます。
フッツーはね？
卵そのまま割っちゃうんですけどぉ
割った後に最初に黄身と白身を分けます
ﾀﾞｧｧｧﾝ!
よし。
あうっ！ヤベッ…失敗した…
(´；ω；`)ｳｩｩ…
(´；ω；`)全部落ちちゃった…
ｳｩｩ…
(失敗した卵は、はじめが美味しく飲みました)
なんとか黄身だけを残して、
透明なやつだけ取って下さい。
オッケぇ～～
こういう感じに黄身だけ完全に取っちゃいました。
で先に白い方だけもうご飯にかけちゃいます。
(何故か失敗した時と同じSE)
でこの状態でもうかき混ぜちゃいます
(何故か(略)SE)
はいっ
こんな感じでございます
何故このようになるかというとですね、
本来白身ってドロっとしてるんですけどぉ
ドロっとなっている原因がタンパク質でございます。
でそのドロっとした感じであるタンパク質が
ご飯の熱によって固まります
多分あれですね…たぶんアレです。
黄身を取り除く事によって
先に白身だけをご飯と混ぜることによって
本来ドロっとしているはずのタンパク質が全て均等に
反応することによってフワッとした食感のご飯になりま～す。
ﾊｲ混ぜ終わりました
こんな感じでございます
後は簡単でございます
後は先程とっておいた黄身を
ご飯にかけて
醤油をかけて完成でございます
おっ
おぉーぅふ・・・♂
あぁ～…これは絶対美味しい…
最強フワリー卵かけご飯(改名)
の完成でございます。
うわぁーこれヤバい！チョー混ざりやすい！
なん↑なの?!
なんかメッチャ均等に混ざるんスよ！
もうなんか色がね…(^p^)
こんな感じになりました。
では頂こうと思います。
(息切れ)
ﾔﾊﾞｲﾔﾊﾞｲﾔﾊﾞｲ…(焦)
あー！
アーーッ！
『JUSCO（ジャスコ）』
※’11年3月1日にイオンへ転換※
この動画が良ければGoodボタン、
つまらないと思ったら…
Goodボタン。(選択の余地無し)
よろしくお願いします。
Girls next door !
(テンポ早過ぎと意味不発言過多により
字幕職人死亡のお知らせ)